foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving in storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where that is Dom
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for being with us
America we're so glad you're here my
co-host today number one best-selling
author and host of the Dr John deloney
show Ramsey personality Dr John deloney
we're taking your calls here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five uh I I should probably wait
but I'm not going to because I'm just
really really excited if you happen to
be a fan of or even slightly interested
in Jordan Peterson Dr Jordan Peterson
his podcast on YouTube and his podcast
out there he has a really great guest
that came out today Dr John deloney's on
there for an hour and 48 minutes and did
not say a thing to get himself fired so
it is a great podcast and uh it'll be a
lot of fun these two intellects uh
hanging out together I'll watch and get
some popcorn and just sit there and just
wish I was as smart as as one-fourth of
either one of them but um I'll hang out
and be watching as a fan boy of both of
you congratulations that's a neat hit I
appreciate that yeah it was a very very
hospitable and it was a fun I I miss
sometimes the academic gymnastics that I
got to do in my old job and so it was
fun just to talk in circles and have a
good time
I love it all right again brilliant
brilliant mind man yeah he is Dr John
deloney on Jordan Peterson's podcast
today it hit uh just a few minutes ago
or earlier today so uh you watch it on
YouTube the full thing um that's one way
he puts it out there and he puts it out
in podcast form all over the place as
well so however you choose to consume we
invite you to do so we'll give uh give
Jordan a big push he's speaking for us
this year at Summit uh our entree
Leadership Summit event here in May at
our uh for leadership team and for real
estate real estate for small business
people there'll be some real estate
people there but uh Dr deloney and uh
Jordan are two of our speakers on that
line up
um
along with Malcolm Gladwell and myself
and several others so it's going to be a
quite a knock down drag out lineup gonna
be a lot of fun Thomas starts off this
hour in uh Franklin Tennessee Hey Thomas
how are you
I'm doing great how about yourself
better than I deserve sir how can we
help
I just had a quick question about what
to do with uh parents saying possible
nursing home and then wanting to divide
up the farm and I didn't know if that
was a
good option or if we they should just
wait till they might need the money to
help pay medical bills
the reason for dividing up the farm is
what
well the my dad wants to do it before
uh they might end up in a nursing home
he's wanting to give his family
the the farm before he's worried about
the nursing homes taking his farm is
basically what it is okay
bad news
he has the money to pay for nursing home
he gets to pay for the nursing home yeah
he's probably got
yeah he's probably got 200 000 I think
holding in the bank how old is he 80.
okay
um so let me tell you there's only two
kinds of Nursing Home
nursing home you pay for
and Welfare nursing home called Medicaid
that is for poor people
yeah your dad don't qualify he's not
poor people that's no okay I agree and
no amount of splitting up the farm
qualifies him for welfare nor is he a
man who would have ever signed up for
welfare
true nor does he want to be in a welfare
Medicaid nursing home by the way I agree
okay so let's just start figuring out
how we're going to pay for this and uh
start allocating some cash that way how
big is the farm
about 150 acres okay so what do you
think the market value of it is
well a lot of stuff around here has been
selling for probably 20 000 acre
okay so like three million bucks
yes sir okay and and he's owned it a
long time
oh yes sir okay all right here's what
you guys need to do all right number one
uh you guys need to sit down with an
estate planner and here's what they're
going to explain to you and it's fairly
simple idea okay
if he dies today
and you inherit the farm and you turn
around and sell the farm within six
months your taxes are zero
okay if he Deeds the farm to you
and then he dies
your taxes are zero because your basis
in the farm at the time of a time you
inherit anything is the market value of
it when you inherit it and so if you
inherit it at three million dollars you
and your brothers and sisters and you
sell it for three million dollars within
six months you have zero taxes because
it's called a stepped up basis your
basis for tax purposes as if your cost
basis is market value at the time of
death you follow me
yes sir if and state he instead he Deeds
it to you prior your basis of a gift
which is what that is
is what he paid for it
which was next to nothing
so we just created taxes on three
million dollars for no reason I would
not do that
okay I would receive it at death
okay much more efficient much better
absolutely yeah but you need to sit down
with an estate planner and lay out what
he wants to have done and he needs to
write it down and that's called a will
and you're freaking 80 years old get
your will done
absolutely seriously okay it's just
responsible thing to do and then the
second thing you do is you sit down with
an investment advisor and um you start
studying nursing homes as a concept
because there's a vast array of price
ranges out there and services available
and ways to do things this guy's a
millionaire if we sell off three hundred
thousand dollars worth of this land now
to pay for his care his best bet from
quality of life and
cost is probably just hire a nurse and
stay in the house
okay 24 7. in-home care that's what you
do when you're a millionaire
okay yes sir you just you get to stay in
your house and they come and take care
of you there it's a higher quality of
care it's a one-on-one care they don't
have seven beds they're caring for
they're caring for one and it's more
expensive but it's less expensive
because you're not providing housing and
food you're already providing that and
so it actually ends up being more
efficient and a higher quality situation
for a millionaire to do that but it's
trouble on you guys because you got to
keep hiring the nurses and make sure
they're coming in there and taking care
of him checking on him and all that but
it's still the best deal anyway you
could do that or you can check out
nursing homes start shopping finding out
what they actually cost and go got 200
Grand when I burn through that how are
we going to what's the next thing we're
gonna do and lay out a game plan for
God's sakes
giving up the forms not your plan dude
as a family want this land I've I live
out out there in Tennessee in the hills
and man there's a lot of we're going to
keep this forever and the kids don't
want it forever and it just gets messy
yeah he you know what are we gonna do
with it upon death that's right maybe
maybe Thomas he lives here maybe he
wants it he wants it right brother
sisters don't let's figure out how we're
gonna buy each other out upon death but
it all needs to happen post death for
stepped up basis and you need a plan
with some expertise speaking into it
estate planner and then study nursing
homes this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
foreign
not exactly what the cool kids are
talking about but let's talk about
Estate Planning in nursing homes for
just a second okay
um because the cool kids got parents and
grandparents that are talking about it
number one
you don't get free nursing home unless
you're poor people
and if you lie and hide your stuff to
act like poor people that's called fraud
and they're really tough on it by the
way they will look back five years you
move everything out of Grandpa's name
into your name and then you stick
grandpa in a Medicaid nursing home
they're going to look back five years if
they find it was four years and nine
months you move the farm into your name
they're going to come back get the farm
because you defrauded the government
you lied
let's just be real clear nursing home
has a different place in our psyche and
Thomas kind of brought this up he used
the phrase that a lot of people phrase
I'm afraid the nursing home is going to
get all my money
no one says that when they go to the car
dealer
because they're trading money for a car
no one says that when they're going to a
restaurant because they're trading money
for someone to cook their food for them
no one says that when you go to a hotel
because they provide you a warm bed
but when it's a nursing home suddenly
they're a bunch of crooks no they're
providing a service taking care of you
when you are your least attractive by
the way and in the most horrible of
situations
and um you're provide they're providing
a service and you get to pay for it like
you do for everything else they are not
Crooks they are not ripping you off they
are providing us you don't say about the
hospital Hospital's gonna get all my
money you're like no please keep me from
dying you know same thing is true in the
nursing home so first thing is you don't
get to dodge this bullet second thing is
once you're 60 years old unless you've
got millions of dollars you should get
long-term care insurance which is
nursing home insurance it covers good
policies cover in-home care which I was
discussing earlier or out of care now
here's the thing in like most States
In-Home Care would be like 50 Grand a
year right roughly most nursing homes
states are going to be 80 to 100 Grand a
year
give or take okay so just plan on that
but here's the thing you can plan on by
the time you get to the nursing home
sorry
but I'm just helping you with the
statistics not your little Feelings by
the time you get to the nursing home
you're at the end
statistically you will last 2.4 years
if you break a hip three months
statistically
okay so the average nursing home stay is
2.4 years average that means some stay
longer but nobody stays 24 years in a
freaking nursing home
so the nursing home is not going to get
three million dollars from you all right
they're not going to get that much okay
they're going to get 50 to 100 000 a
year depending on what you sign up for
and that kind of a thing for caring for
you in your last days when you are your
least attractive so shut up seriously
okay so plan it out have in long-term
care insurance does not cover long term
it covers long-term care for two to
three years so it'll cover you for the
averages so if you do a 10-year nursing
home stay your long-term care insurance
is going to run out and you're going to
be under your assets
you've been answering this question for
years why why do people have this
feeling I have a hypothesis but I may be
wrong why do you think people are so
adverse to
nursing homes
I I I have a weird answer it's probably
going to get me a bunch of hate okay but
I'm gonna do it anyway okay because you
just put me on I'll follow up with mine
I'll join you
if it was me yes
and you're going to spend my last 300
Grand on Dave
it feels selfish
and it feels and I'm gonna die anyway it
feels like a waste
so I I mean is that is that is that
right I mean no no no just being real if
it's me that's how I'm gonna feel if
it's old man Papa Dave and I'm 82 years
old 88 years old whatever I am right
they know where you're living I'm gonna
feel like hey I ain't got anything
anyway just get cook some carrots and
put me out in the backyard I mean it's
good you know I mean it's just like I
don't want to spend a bunch of money on
this because I'm just it feels wasteful
to me that's just my personal emotions I
don't know if everybody else see I was
thinking of it more as the kid of the
adults all trying to get the money well
thinking if I know you got 300 Grand
I've already spent my portion in my head
on I'm gonna pay this off and then
Junior's gonna go to college what do you
mean you're going to spend that on this
kind of care yeah and then it becomes
that's my money versus that's the money
that you set aside to care for yourself
yeah if you've got a relative that has
entitlement syndrome on to your stuff
called they've already spent your
inheritance and you ain't even kicked a
bucket yet
um then that's uh that that could cause
a problem in this discussion too but I
don't usually run into that no I usually
it's Mom and Dad how much of it is I
can't tell you it's two more times I had
a call and I already transferred the
land ah man and they're like yeah and
you know my we already mama she read she
talked to her friend at the bridge club
who told her to transfer her house into
our name and you know they're calling me
from North Egypt somewhere right some
out in the middle of nothing and they're
going oh my gosh and I'm going you just
transferred your only asset which is a
150 000 house that you paid 22 000 for
in 1976 and now you're paying taxes on
139 you're gonna pay taxes on all that
gain because your mother took tax advice
from the idiot at the bridge club you
know and this missed out on the stepped
up basis and cool how much how much of
it is
they don't want the government to get is
what that was no let me say this way and
so let's pretend you're my dad
I would have some inside deep inside
sense of it should probably be me taking
care of him
oh guilt you should probably be at my
house and the fact that I've got to
Outsource that is going to be I'm gonna
be extra
on top of it
coming over the top of my own guilt of
my own shame yeah maybe that's just me
yeah and there's this whole thing and
then we christianize it and say honor
your mother and father which as as if
you caring for them instead of a
professional caring for them is more
honoring
oh yeah yeah really give me a break I
actually uh taught that in Sunday school
this week with the adults class about
honorary father mother was that actually
mean and what does it look like to care
for aging adults and somebody brought up
a great point they said there's a the
honor is a part of it and Care is a
separate part of that conversation and I
never never pulled that apart yeah we do
confuse the two when we want to
especially if we want to over
spiritualize it we want to over guilt
somebody yeah if we're oversaved
there we go
unless you're under safe James tell you
we're gonna get we're going to get those
emails for sure all right hey guys it's
not Friday it's Monday November the 21st
but here at Ramsey Black Friday starts
right now at the ramsaysolutions.com get
your Early Access to do our best deals
of the Year prices as low as seven
dollars uh no inflation is not taking
place at ramsaysolutions.com we are
doing deflation lower prices for real I
sell that today not only but not only my
book didn't go up but we've cut John's
book to ten dollars out on my books
that's the first time ever happened to
me it was insulting does that insult you
I mean it's like my new baby steps
millionaire number one bestseller just
came out in January they already cut it
to 10. I did I did the math on what I
was gonna get if it sold the full price
so I was surprised but all this is all
personal now I mean I was just insulted
on the general premise my book was cheap
you're worried about your wallet that's
right all right questions for human
conversation cards great great for the
holidays bad news the Christmas Version
John told me a minute ago is completely
sold out is that right Christmas
version's out but we have a few New
Year's cards left and these are for
helping you have a conversation with
your awkward friends and adults yes
get into the new year man with some
intentionality this year yeah all right
let's check in on blinds.com uh find out
for yourself whyblinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping new
promos they run all the time you'll save
even more I don't know if we got time to
do this let's try it all right today's
question comes from Bill in Rhode Island
37 I found out my I found myself in a
lucky spot three years ago I was making
around 50 Grand now I'm clearing over
120 as a cloud engineer don't even know
what that is my wife and I combined make
about 180 for people like us it's a bit
overwhelming we have student debt which
we're attacking hard we have recently
been writing checks towards that debt
that we used to make up for an entire
month my question is how do you
psychologically process this amount of
money growth and don't feel shaken up
and paying off large sums debt we're
gonna do this after the break that's a
good great question I don't want to
answer it in 14 seconds
probably should have waited left the
break but now we can tease you through
the break you know you want the answer
to this how do you psychologically
adjust to making a butt load more money
yeah it's not by selling ten dollar
books
is the Ramsay show
foreign
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author host of
the Dr John deloney's show featured on
the Jordan Peterson podcast this week is
my co-host quite an introduction at
every break yeah okay so blinds.com
let's go back again and read this our
question of the day from blinds.com the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings always use the promo
code Ramsay when you get there now do it
again all right today's question comes
from Bill in Rhode Island bill says I'm
37 and I really found myself in a lucky
spot just three years ago I was making
around 50 Grand and now I'm clearing
over a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars as a cloud engineer brain dancer
he's a rain dancer correct just making
sure you know what that is my wife and I
combined make about a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars and to be honest for
people like us man I hate that language
but I know it I feel it in my guts it's
a bit overwhelming we have student debt
which we were attacking hard and we have
recently been writing checks towards
that debt that used to be what we made
for an entire month my question is how
do you psychologically process this
amount of money growth and don't feel
shaken up when paying off large sums of
debt I also know more is coming as my
wife and I are committed to not allow
I'm not even at a management level which
on average comes with a 30 increase my
wife and I are committed not to allow
our growth and income to become the life
sucker I've heard about on this show
I get this at a in my bones because I
grew up with not a lot and money was a
big struggle at my home and Dave you and
I I've come to you for wisdom on this
um
because money was for those people and
vacations were what those guys did and
those shoes were what they and those
cars were for them and it was it it's
it's bizarre finding yourself
in those shoes and then saying what I do
because I'm not them I'm one of those
right
yeah I think there's it's pretty tough
there's two things you gotta processed
there
um one is uh am I worthy of this and
he's got that language I just got lucky
there's all that in there and so yeah
you got to walk away from that part of
it and then the second part is
kind of I think more maybe even more
what he's asking about but he didn't
realize it is
um
you do have to psychologically adjust to
more money I mean it's it's it's a thing
I mean I like we spend more on coffee
at Ramsey per month
for the team here than I used to make in
a year
I have to psychologically adjust to that
I mean when I sit down and I see that on
the p l p l it's still
simultaneously pisses me off scares me
makes me feel proud right exactly all
this all at the same time yes all the
same time like what and oh God and well
I guess I can do that you know it's like
yeah yeah simultaneously right and so
it's God and it but it's it's zeros it's
emotional and uh the only way I have
found for that part of it not the
identity part but the part of just the
shock of the zeros of I spend more on
blank than I ever made in a year which
is kind of what he said we just sent off
more than Sally made than I ever made in
a year before or a month before or
whatever it is you just the only way you
you get used to it is you do it more
you just you live anymore I mean so
somebody that has lived with a 300 000
income
for 10 years is more psychologically
adjusted to that than someone who's
lived with it for three months and so
that that's normal so that will solve
itself uh and you got to be careful
because you can get
to taking it for granted kind of a thing
um and not counting your blessings and
all of those sorts of things not feeling
grateful for us like now you deserve now
I deserve 300 what do you mean just 300.
never even solved 300 there's a 300
pennies you know
um and but no no I am but then the
second part of it is you know are you
worthy and you know you have to that's a
spiritual
walk and a psychological walk to say
okay what makes me worth something in
the marketplace is it my is it God loves
me more well no he loves poor people as
much as he loves rich people and he
loves rich people as much as he loves
poor people for those of you that are
socialists and so um he loves everybody
that and it doesn't a lot you know
you'll love one kid that's talented more
than the kid that's not talented sure
um you know you they're just all my kids
I got you know everybody's got a
spectrum of them you know and so that's
part of it so God it's not a God's love
thing he's not blessing you beyond
someone else
um so what is it that's causing the
money it's you're doing something that's
worth more to society it's an economic
transaction and once you kind of
separate that out from your spiritual
Worth or your psychological Worth or and
then some idiot from the old
neighborhood will say something like
you've gotten too big for your breath oh
yeah yeah like you noticed yeah I've
been putting on the weight locking
Donuts but yeah I had to change britches
a time or two but that wasn't what they
were meant that's right they were
talking about my waistline they were
talking about uh you're fancy now yeah
you're fancy now and you know that
happened actually on this show you know
you go back and listen to
this show if you could get a tape of it
from 20 years ago it's been I've been on
there for 30 years it sounds
ridiculously exactly the same
like the same level of boldness the same
level of carrying on the same level or
whatever same level of kindness and
compassion when someone's hurting the
same level of interface when you're
stupid and and yet it never fails that
someone comes along they go you know I
used to listen to you but now now that
you've gotten big
you know now you changed well I didn't
change honey go back and listen to other
shows you're the one changed
so I thought that's interesting I've had
to get rid of for People Like Us
language like he writes about this
question because I had pigeonholed
myself as identity it's an identity yeah
and you gave me some wisdom early on
that has really been important for me in
fact just this morning I was talking to
Hank about it my 12 year old
um you said when you're making this
transition remember ratios and that's
been very important for me in that like
you like man if we could scratch
together Sheila and I we could scratch
together enough to get some spaghetti
every day for the week man that was
great yeah right and then we went out
with a couple from work the other day
and the bill came and I thought that I
used to be a lot of groceries all right
and but the percentage of right and the
percentage of what my take-home salary
what used to be versus and so in my debt
income all that the ratio has been
really important yeah it just it tells
you if you're out of line that's exactly
right okay because you're not people
like like you used to be you're people
like you are now that's right and so
don't I you know your identity can be I
came from there it's like condoleezza's
Rice's uh uh line it doesn't matter
where you're coming from all that
matters where you're going to that's
right and so you know if you don't where
you grew up is is part of your story but
it is not necessarily who you are today
that's right your level of education is
part of your story but it's not
necessarily who you are today
um these are all elements of who you are
today but
um I'm not the same person
that little David Ramsey at 3713
Faulkner driveway and thank goodness
right yeah because he wasn't real bright
John deloney wasn't either but I also
Imagine the dumb butt stuff I've done on
the bus I appreciate you
and everyone we work with
um
I I think the ethos of this place it's
right over there on the wall don't
despise humble beginnings
um always making sure we're tipping
folks and taking care of people never
forgetting those moments that when when
you couldn't rub two pennies together
right I think I think there's an ethos
here yeah and and in that sense you
remember
you know what is the hillbilly my
hillbilly upbringing don't forget you're
raising I'll Always Love raisins but I
don't know what they're talking about
how you were brought up don't forget how
you're brought up right and so there's
some good things you want to do with
that I'm loyal to vendors that have been
with us forever because part of my
raising was you danced with a girl that
brought you yep you know so there's some
good things in there
um that you stick with that are
principles but the identity that the
only way I'm holy me is to be poor
right not true that's right that's a
that's a false identity so yeah there's
two things you have to do is one you
have to adjust the identity and the
second thing is you just get used to
practice with ratios the uh the use of
money of that amount and it's going to
mean you're driving cars and you're
going to look up and you go I got a
friend made 15 million dollars last year
and he drove up another day in a 400 000
car and I'm like
oh wait a minute it's it's less than a
guy making 150 000 spending on a four
thousand dollar car exactly the same
ratio
it's no big deal yeah I mean he could
drive a stupid thing off a cliff and as
long as nobody's hurt it ain't gonna
hurt him he'll be all right it's like
you know but it's in my where you know
where you come from is like your system
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Dr John deloney show
is my co-host today and we talk a lot
about the things you need to do to be
successful with money let me tell you
what one I miss
you need to learn not only gratitude but
unbelievable generosity and generosity
is actually a muscle you can build
this is a time of year when we have the
opportunity to build that and your
generosity muscle you can start you can
start building it in your children when
they're young you can just decide today
I'm going to change my generosity you
can decide the amount of money the
percentage uh the methodology uh those
of us that are Evangelical Christians we
start with a tithe 10 of our income to
our local church but you start wherever
you want to start but generosity is a
keystone among people who win at life
and at money now I find a few people not
many but a few percentage-wise I would
say less than 10 percent probably
approaching five percent that actually
do very well with money who are just
straight up Scrooge and they're selfish
but the vast majority 95 plus that do
well with money also have their
generosity muscle built and it affects
their handling of money in a positive
way they end up with more money because
they're generous so we do an annual
giving show this year it'll be on
December the 14th it's our last live
broadcast that's not the uh truth we're
doing it earlier this year we're not
doing it as our last live it usually is
our last live broadcast of the Year
James is correcting me this year we're
going to do it early December the 14th
and we're going to hear giving stories
and receiving stories some of you that
have had your mind blown
by some giving you've been involved in
or had your mind blown by some receiving
that has happened to you and all of this
is to inspire America to be more
generous
if I add up what we spend on Halloween
decorations and on pets
we could not have a single hungry person
in America today and we could build six
hospitals and operate them for a decade
the size of Saint Jude's free care just
what we spend on Halloween decorations
and pets now I'm not against Halloween
decorations and I'm not against pets I'm
saying there's money in this country
that's all I'm saying and generosity
always is a good thing for the whole
society and you as an individual so we
always want to inspire more of that so
send your giving and receiving stories
to be part of the December 14th uh show
to ask at ramseysolutions.com ask at
ramsaysolutions.com I dare say some
chemicals are Unleashed in the brain
when you give
it's one of my favorite episodes of the
year last year I was just sat here in
awe and just inspired it was incredible
man incredible I look forward to um
telling my story about Dave when he buys
us all cars I'm pretty excited about
that I'm just kind of putting that out
into the universe are you yeah the
universe just said no
I tried guys sorry I speak to the
universe regularly you do it listens to
you man it never listens to me
just responds in the voice of Dave or my
wife
Mike is in Montana hey Mike how are you
I'm doing well how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up
good uh well uh my wife and I have been
in babysit 3D for about 30 months now
and we are wondering uh we're getting a
little too long and we should start
moving things around or what
um we're in an area where we think that
we can find a house for 180
uh it's a sale price
um and
my take-home pay is such that 25 would
make us have a 51 000 down payment
uh but if we cheated that 25 up to 30 we
would only need 28 which is about what
we would have by the summer
so I'm wondering if that's something
that is
acceptable or if I'm if I if we should
just go take a cold shower or something
you know okay let's pan back for a
second and say okay why do we have a
ratio on the size of house payment
not not how much can I get away with why
do we why do we teach you that well we
teach you that because if your house
payment is too freaking big
as a percentage of your income you can't
breathe
you have no margin and then everything
other than the house becomes a crisis
because the house is pinching you and
that's what we in our business call
house poor now you know all that right
Mike
yes sir okay and so to the extent you go
over 25 percent you start moving in that
direction
but I've had people call here with a
house payment that's 50 of their
take-home pay and no kidding they can't
breathe they've got to sell that house
if they can't double their income pretty
quick so if you want to quote unquote
cheat yourself because there's no one
else in this discussion but you and your
wife and your kids right you treat
yourself in your future up on the 30
side because you've got a little bit of
house fever what's the trade-off well
under what circumstances would that be
wise or less wise okay uh if if your
company is announcing that it's probably
going to have layoffs this summer well
that would be totally stupid then
okay if you're in a job where your
income's probably going to go up 30
percent in the next two years
then pretty quickly your house payment
is going to be 25 percent of your
take-home pay if you're going to uh buy
this house at 30 of your income and then
have the third baby and your wife says
she wants to be home and now it's 48 of
your take-home pay well that's obviously
not going to work so it kind of has to
do with future plans right
so how stable is your income what do you
mean what do you do
uh well I'm actually switching into a
job
um I'm going to calculate uh switching
into Tech from being a trucker
um so that's
uh paying for school for that is part of
why it's taking us you know the 30
months and three baby step 3B okay when
will you when will you be making the
switch
uh that'll be end of next summer August
September somewhere in there
um and we're we're basing these numbers
on what I'm estimating that to be my
wife is planning on coming home she's
currently working as a nurse she's
planning and coming home when we have
her third child in May whoa whoa
like I've done this before or something
okay yes exactly I was thinking the same
thing all right and so yeah so you know
when the Smoke Clears you're at 30 in a
new career
correct yep um and until the Smoke
Clears you're better than 30 percent
because your trucker plus her income
before the third kid comes in before you
switch no no no the the 30 will be based
on just my income
um after I switch jobs yeah that's why I
said When the Smoke Clears and she quits
oh yeah yeah and she quits yeah so but
it should be more it should be less than
30 with both of you working in the
meantime right
what do you think the trajectory is on
your income after you get the new job um
the information I have says that it'll
go up quite a bit
um okay then you're not going to be at
30 for very long
okay so what we're looking at here is we
want to look at the film strip not the
snapshot
okay the film strip is your whole life
all the way out are we are we strapping
ourselves to a house long term and what
you're doing is you're going in and out
start with you're going to be below then
you're going to be up to 30. and then
you're going but 30 is just passing
through because then four months into
the new job you get another raise right
or whatever eight percent whatever that
kind of thing so you may have one year
of tight
but it's not but your plan is not to
live a life of being home house poor
then that starts to be more wise than I
work for the state I get a three percent
raise every year and my wife's gonna
quit in two years and then we're really
going to be screwed no we're not signing
up for that one
right okay you see the difference
I do see the difference yes sir yeah so
that so Dave this makes me nervous okay
because I maybe it's my years of working
with young professionals but
I can't think of a group that
overestimates what they're going to be
making in 18 months and then make
current fiscal decisions based on this
imaginary growth that may or may not
come that makes sense yeah so here's the
thing here's what you might be facing
what John's pointing out if this doesn't
go the way you think you may be faced
with your wife keeps working or you have
to sell the house
or if you had if you had to stay a
trucker in three years could you make
this house payment
no
um yeah no not without going over the
road which is something not not with her
coming home yeah yeah so you may end up
trading her being home for this house if
the career path doesn't work out like
you're playing so you have to go all in
on the career plan right yeah you got to
make this thing work yeah yeah and or
you go hey it's just a house we give it
a shot and it's more important that we
move to a smaller house is more
important than she stays home that's
right and that's what that's more
important to us than that particular
house yeah and you just sell the house
also you can refinance the house when
interest rates come down
that'll help this is the Ramsey chef
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18
minutes listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
King in the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love
create actual amazing relationships Dr
John baloney Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we take your questions about
your life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five David is calling from Saigon
Vietnam I think that's my first call
from Saigon in 30 years David how are
you
hi I'm good thanks how are you good what
are you doing in Saigon
um uh living abroad I've been living uh
my wife and I have been living abroad
for about 16 years but our investments
and properties are in the U.S cool what
do you do for a living and
uh International Educator
okay I teach the teacher yeah I was
going to say that sounded a lot like art
vandelay's importer exporter from
Seinfeld I've got a nice I'll actually
have a good friend whose brother lives
in Saigon that is in your business and
I'm wondering if you're him anyway yeah
all right go ahead brother how can we
help maybe I know him
um well um okay we uh we're big fans of
the baby steps we've done them all we've
done them all except for one and I might
get in trouble from you on this one and
that is that we have two rental
properties that um that are turning um a
profit and we don't want to pay off the
rest of the mortgage because we feel
like we're making more having that money
invested in the market
so and I know you uh with your baby
steps you um highly I recommend paying
off those mortgages or thinking why do
that if we can make more if that money
is in the market
can you share your wisdom oh you want to
know why I should do that oh I see okay
and how much money how much money do you
have in Investments
uh a little over a million good for you
well done how old are you
uh 57. excellent and how much are these
mortgages
uh they're about 170 each so 340 knocks
it out and that leaves you with 660 in
your investment if we use that
investment who will to do that okay is
that right
uh yes okay and so really what we're
discussing is how much more you would
make on three hundred and forty thousand
over the interest
on the houses okay now here's the thing
um
I first approached this through the lens
of faith it was my first approach
because I have all the letters and
licenses after my name the academic crap
that says I'm supposed to know something
about money but I went broke so
apparently I did something wrong
um and I and so I discovered uh common
sense and what the Bible says about
money and I can't find anywhere as a
Christian this is my my journey not
yours okay I can't find anywhere in the
Bible ever that says anything positive
about debt it's not a Salvation issue
you're not going to hell because you
have debt it's not a God loves you less
if you have that it's all negative
though
the borrower is slave to the lender
and it goes on and on and on and on and
on all the negative references from that
so as as part of my faith walk I had to
say Okay God must know something or that
I don't understand about debt because I
was taught if you can borrow money at
um you know three four five percent on
your mortgage and you can invest it in a
mutual fund and make 10 or 12 then
you're making that spread that Arbitrage
which is what you're discussing correct
yes exactly now as I've gone forward
what I've discovered is that the vast
majority of wealthy people that we've
studied
uh but people of Faith or otherwise have
avoided debt and gotten out of debt and
uh and have stayed away from it and I
kind of had to stop and go why is that
and I find very few people now you're
not highly leveraged but I find very few
people that are highly leveraged that
actually survive the people that borrow
money like crazy to buy rental
properties and doing Airbnb and all this
crap they're all broke in 10 years I
went broke doing that within within 10
years and so you can't find someone
that's been doing that for 20 years and
survived one of these economic Cycles
takes their head off
and so what that means is that debt
equals risk more debt equals more risk
and I think we can all agree to that can
you
uh yes yeah you have little you have a
small amount of debt so it doesn't feel
like a lot of risk it's not as much risk
as if you had 3.4 million agreed
correct yeah no that's all I'm saying
more debt is more risk less debt is less
risk zero debt is approaching zero risk
and the only thing the only math formula
I have found that adjusts for risk does
not exist in the real estate world it's
only in the investment world and we
adjust for risk using the math formula
of a beta a beta is the height of a uh
if you do Peaks and valleys of an
investment it goes up and down up and
down up and down the the difference in
the Val the difference in the peak and
the valley is called a beta you're and
it's your the higher beta is a higher
volatility a a steeper mountain and a
more often cycle does that make sense
yes and in the investment world we use a
beta the higher the beta the higher the
risk because the more volatile it is and
we use an inverse relationship in the
math meaning you drop it under the
denominator and get nerdy here but the
that gives you the ability to calculate
risk into the investment and measure a
risky investment against a not so risky
investment that has a lower beta and
you've you've neutralized for risk
therefore you can compare Them Apples to
Apples we don't enter risk into the
formula that you used to tell me you
wanted to keep your debt if we put risk
in that formula and you do have some
risk not as much as if you had 3.4
million but if we put a low beta in your
formula it starts to neutralize into a
way with all your spread the other thing
that happens is when you don't have any
payments you just straight up sleep
better
that's true and I've done a high and
I've done detailed research 100 of the
foreclosures occur on a house with a
mortgage
and so I uh I would tell you this let's
do this you could try this if you want
to I would pay them both off
and if you hate it
go get you on the mortgage later
okay
um okay fair enough uh can I ask you
another question a follow-up question
then so it should be scared to after
that long answer
back in stats class all that money out
we're going to pay we're gonna pay
through the nose and taxes pulling it
all out of all of our uh our retirement
Investments how old are you so it's like
oh you're 57. no I would not take it out
of retirement is it all in retirement
yeah this is all this you don't have any
money that's not in retirement
we have yeah we have some how much we
have it
um a couple hundred well I'd use that
then tada
yeah and you have a good income and I
would just no I'm not going to cash out
and pay penalties on your retirement I
was not suggesting that but because that
changes the formula now you may have
some capital gains on it and I I would
do that I have lived 100 debt free since
I went broke 30 something years ago and
I have had a wonderful life I've made a
lot of money I have a lot of Investments
and they're all paid for and when crap
happens like the Island of Misfit Toys
is misbehaving up in Washington DC right
now and they're screwing up the whole
freaking economy I'm sitting here
peaceful and slept really good last
night except that my four-year-old
grandson put a plastic snake under my
pillow but other than that I slept great
last night that really did happen good
for him uh I told him his new name is
Sneaky Snake I like it that's his new
nickname when he come when I go to his
rehearsal dinner in 24 years I'm gonna
introduce her sneaky snake that's it I'm
gonna throw that snake at him I'm saving
it this is the Ramsay show
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
thank you
foreign
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today JC is with us in Fort
Worth Hey JC what's up
Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving to you
how can we help
overwhelmed about our house and really
not sure what to do about it
um the short story is that since August
we've had
some major home repairs totaling about
um forty thousand dollars that are going
to send us back into Consumer Debt
because we don't have that kind of cash
in the bank
so I guess my question is at what point
do we cut our losses and say goodbye to
this house
okay what kind of home repairs pop up so
suddenly and unexpectedly
right so
um
we had to get our HVAC replaced in
August
um when we bought the house it was only
two years old which we thought you know
was a dream what did you pay for that
so the HVAC was about 15. we got the
lowest Seer that we could so you paid
for that that's done
um no we had to finance that
so you had no money when you moved in
the house
well so we moved into the house in 2019
um and you had no money
when you're when your HVAC went out
so we have we have about 13 000 in the
bank and so we could pay for most of it
yes but you didn't
no we did not okay so what is it on you
want me to so you're trying to decide
whether to keep the house what was the
other thing that went wrong yeah so the
foundation
um
basically with the drought that we had
in Texas this summer the house was
falling apart at the seams major cracks
um so we we actually had gotten a quote
for the foundation a couple years ago
and it was only 4 000 at the time and
then we ended up
waiting on it and it ended up being a
lot more so that was 95 and then two
what was 95 you've already done it
yeah so you've already financed that too
yes Oh I thought you told me you were
going had to do these repairs and then
you were going to be in debt so you've
already made all these decisions
well there's one there's one more
decision that
and so to validate the warranty for the
the lifetime the um the lifetime
warranty on the foundation we need to
pass a plumbing test and we failed that
and the minimum repairs for that are
thirteen thousand but they're not
entirely sure that that's going to fix
it they the same people that did the
foundation did the plumbing repair
no no it was a different company are
they friends
yes they are and I've been working on
getting um yes they can trench up your
entire yard for less than that that's
absolute BS okay I'd call another
company to come out and start I'm
calling BS I'm calling a lawyer you're
going to certify this dead gum
Foundation that you put in for ten
thousand dollars today
period
this idea that I have to get Plumbing
done from your friend before I get your
warranty on work you did BS I'm about to
bust somebody in the chops
okay
I don't think you're gonna do it are you
because you're convinced that you're
convinced the whole damn thing's falling
down
yeah I am yeah right and so yeah I think
you want to sell it because you don't
like you're mad at the house
very true yes yeah so what's this piece
of garbage worth
it's probably worth about well it's
maybe 300 000. it might be a little we
might have to you know take a little bit
less on it now with what do you owe on
it I'm slowing down about 180 okay
all right uh I think you're going to
sell your house because I think you hate
your house
but I also think you've got to figure
out a way to start living your life
without drama to drama to debt to debt
yeah it's not going because you're
always gonna have drama around the house
and you're gonna have to you're not to
finish you're going to finish borrowing
money on it and you're gonna have to
think differently about the process but
I I don't know about your husband but I
do know about his wife she's tired of
this house she's ready to move
I think my husband is more tired than I
am actually
I mean but now you're gonna get
everything all fixed I'm gonna I'm not
doing the plumbing Bozo that did the
repair on the uh foundations about to
issue me a warranty or I'm about to come
after him for doing work that he can't
warranty
this is a problem this is a problem and
I smell a rat and yeah it stinks
so could be wrong not calling him a
crook just saying sure does look like
one
and so uh that's what I'm doing and then
I'm gonna put the house on the market
and sell the crap out of it and move and
this time by something that and listen
and then and then stop this garbage stop
all this justification and we're stuck
and it's the only thing
we're trapped and all this stuff happens
to us you're gonna have to happen to hit
right and it's time that you guys get
control of this stuff and if you buy a
house in the DFW area you're gonna have
Foundation challenges you're going to
have air conditioning I mean that just
just got to make peace with that if
you're gonna be a homeowner in some of
those areas yeah yeah which means you
can't like you mentioned you can't buy a
house you don't have any money and you
also get a good home inspection before
you buy the house right yeah and um you
should know with a good home inspection
if you have more than two years of life
left in the HVAC yes
um you gotta you got a 12 year old HVAC
it's come it's coming shortly get ready
you know I mean it's working perfect now
yeah yeah it won't be for long it's
coming at you I mean you know you got a
four-year-old HVAC you should get more
than two more years out of it hello so
um I mean this is you know it's basic
stuff these things have a life
and a lifespan and the lifespan is only
so long you said it Dave
um and it reminds me
uh
JC you're gonna sell this house you're
gonna buy a new house
and if you don't quickly and
dramatically deal with the drama in your
home
with how y'all handle money how y'all
handle each other how you handle
um YOLO versus we're gonna say slow down
and save up for Stuff
you're going to realize in short order
they're going to buy a new house and you
and your husband went with you
and they are going to show up at that
new house there's going to be more we
need this we got to buy this and we
gotta have this and this is gonna break
and the whole cycle starts over again
yeah
part of me thinks the spiritual exercise
would be to sit there for a couple three
months six months and make peace with
your relationship with your husband and
y'all make peace with decision making
and then get into something else then
you're not going to do that but man
there's something about running for mess
to mess to mess you said it Dave you got
to deal with the drama or it's just
gonna follow you
it's gonna follow you follow you follow
you follow you and this is Thanksgiving
it's probably not a bad idea to sell
your house in the spring rather than at
Christmas
some you know in terms of Market timing
or whatever
um so it might be it's okay yeah go
ahead and bust on the foundation guy get
that certified and then just sit there
enjoy the new property get it get you
know start you know spend a month or two
clean it up get ready to sell start
talking about putting it on the market
in March in the meantime in the meantime
get your head around
okay we're gonna control these
controllables these variables coming at
us are not going to control us
and uh when you live from stress to
stress to crisis to crisis debt to debt
um it's a cycle that you have to
intellectually in an act of your will
break that cycle and it's not easy to do
um I was the same way I mean
uh we're at our house Ramses we are
built-in drama queens oh I mean we can
add drama to anything so it's one of my
spiritual gifts man
so Ian Crone created a a tenth Enneagram
for me just for you just drama queen
number 10 on anything that's right and
so yeah that's it and uh you know so I
understand where you're doing but one of
the things I had to do is I had to break
myself from feeling like these
circumstances were controlling me
these things coming at me were
controlling me and there's that sense of
power of backing up three steps and go
yeah maybe not
Maybe not maybe we're not using your
buddy to fix it for Me Maybe we're just
gonna bust you in the nose maybe not
yeah it's a whole different way of
looking at things this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Chris and Brianna are with us
hey guys how are you hey guys great
welcome where do you all live Atlanta
Georgia oh cool welcome to Nashville and
all the way here to do a debt free
scream how much did you pay off
seventy six thousand eight hundred and
forty dollars and Ninety Four Cents love
it how long did this take 27 months wow
and your range of income during that
time
um after taxes it was a hundred and
forty thousand to a hundred and fifty
thousand awesome what do you all do for
a living
um I'm a counselor and a virtual health
and fitness coach and I own a small
landscaping company oh very good very
good good careers both of you what kind
of debt was the 77 000. it was mostly
student loans
um and then the rest of it so about 53
000 low student loans and then the rest
of it was Consumer Debt now how long you
been out of school oh I've I've been out
of school since 2004. we've been
borrowing money since we got married
yeah okay 20 years 22 years we've been
married 22 years but 30 months ago 27
months ago
what happened what turned the corner for
you I mean you you changed well I uh I
lost my temper one day after a long hard
day in the hot sun
um I was working a lot we were dealing
with a lot and uh
coveted I mean 27 months ago was Miller
covet right so we really had this
conversation right before covet hit yeah
okay and so at the time we did have six
kids in the house at that time
um and so we had a lot of stress and
then yeah finances were tight and then
it was a long hot day and then what
happened and then I said we got to do
something different yes this ain't
working and that kind of uh rounded off
the edges on that a little bit but
um
you know and so the next day we were at
church and uh like for real what'd you
do like you can't just leave that's like
that's like a middle school when
somebody came up to me I know someone
who likes you and they don't tell you
what happened I just lost my temper I
have a a bad temper
um but I and so we um we heard about uh
your class at 12 Stone Church oh yeah
and so uh we took the class Okay and
like you said covet hit right in the
middle of it yeah so we kind of finished
up online yeah um but
it was uh um it was a it was a hard
decision because I was all I was gung-ho
um and she wasn't so much so right I
mean
I mean I I we had just lived with debt
for so long like there was just a part
of me that didn't really believe that we
could get out of it and so
um and he is very All or nothing and I'm
very in the gray and so approaching the
um the steps you know was a challenge as
far as communication goes and all of
that but we did it so and it's just one
of many schemes you've presented her
over the years or was this listen we
don't got to get into all that
but I mean there could have been a bunch
of opportunities yes and this was just
another and she was like all right yeah
I've always been an entrepreneur okay
I've always tried stuff on my own yeah
so Brianna what what finally brought you
around where you said I'm into well I
mean I'm gonna support whatever he wants
to do and so I just was like
um decided to trust the process I mean I
I knew the prince at one point because
you didn't at first what tell the truth
I mean I didn't at first but I I did it
even without even without believing it
so so yeah so I behaviorally I was all
in but in my head I mean I've been told
my best friends like there's no way this
is gonna work for us okay honestly
um and then when you start believing in
your head that it would work
um I would say about six months in once
we got like once we really had stuff
paid off and we were only getting to the
student loans then I was like I could
see the real traction was happening
um and then last August we still had
like 29 000 left he's like I want to pay
it off by the time the kids get out of
school and that would have been May and
I was like there's no way we're gonna do
this and then we did it we sent our last
payment in May before they got out of
school that year yes wow so how'd y'all
how'd you all make it in that last
Sprint
we just got Tighter and Tighter and
every single I mean anything extra that
came into the house went any extra
paychecks went any extra money went
um we were cutting we were budgeting we
had sold extra furniture around the
house and by now you believe oh yeah
yeah
absolutely that makes a difference too
that changes the numbers yeah yeah
that's very cool good for you how has
this changed your marriage
well I mean we're not fighting about
money yeah we don't we don't fight about
money we've never really fought like
hardcore about stuff but
um we we did more of the uh we just
won't talk about it and everything will
be okay we've always been good earners
we just didn't really you remember our
Spenders yeah we just didn't manage it
we didn't manage our money well so our
money didn't really change that much I
mean as you can see from the numbers it
only went up ten thousand so it's all
just behavioral stuff
so when you came home from that long hot
day in the sun before kovitz starts and
this whole thing happens was
um
what what you were mad about money a
money thing I was mad that I was working
so hard and we had no money okay that's
what I meant yeah it's a it's a
disgusted yeah yeah I've been there yeah
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired yeah yeah I worked two dead gum
hard we make a hundred and some thousand
dollars we got nothing yep that that
math that's right mad I like that one
that's righteous anger that causes you
to change your life yeah that's good
very well done guys welcome very
powerful what do you when you look back
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
passion for me
um you gotta get after it as you say a
lot
um I'm outside a lot so I'll listen to
the show a lot
um I'm able to listen to my headphones
most of the day so I just uh I felt like
just staying intense and you know
pushing the envelope and trying to make
as much money as I could yeah they make
it work harder when it's going somewhere
when you see the traction yeah yeah you
can work extra hours you can do all
kinds of stuff yeah good for you very
well done what about you Brianna what do
you say the secret was I think the
secret was to start before you're ready
and to just trust the process yeah
there's something about
um before you're ready acting your way
into this like I'm just gonna I'm gonna
trust the process it's like the Indiana
Jones you know when he just takes that
step and I'm gonna take the next step he
could have sat there and and
intellectualized the whole thing but he
just started walking right and good for
you and you you walk to the path and
suddenly it began to reveal itself oh
this is going to happen right yes good
for you good it's powerful very well
done y'all
not proud of you and you brought the
kiddos with you have them come up what
are their names and ages come on up we
got Emma she is 11. and then we have Ivy
is not
it's not and we have an older one at
home Ryan he's watching the house and
the dog that's a good thing yeah so
that's a good thing okay very cool very
cool well done you guys very well done
hey we've got the live and give bundle
for you that's The Total Money Makeover
book the new baby steps millionaires
book both number one bestsellers for you
to use or give away and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
you've been through it but uh that'll
give it that'll be something you can
give away as well and you'll enjoy
certainly the baby steps millionaire
book that's the next chapter in your
story you're on your way so proud of
y'all thank you well done thank you you
conquered one of the most difficult
territories to conquer and that's the
guy in the mirror yeah it's very
difficult well done very well done and
we can see it on you we can see the body
language it's it's very powerful good
job thank you good job all right Chris
and Brianna Gavin Emma and Ivy wow 77
thousand dollars paid off in 27 months
making 140 to 150. after I got sick and
tired are being sick and tired count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
that's how it's done
wow
what's our friend's name I cannot place
it who wrote the book and he talks about
the only positive
uh or the most one of the most positive
emotions is the emotion of anger
um uh seven oh Dodd chip chip dot thank
you chip dot yeah the anger is the one
that has action associated with it and
uh you know we we always we're all
everybody's so worried about toxic
versions of anger but there's a good
anger that moves you off your get you
off your butt yeah it points you towards
something that you care about and it
helps you recognize this isn't how
things should be and I'm headed to I'm
headed right in the middle of it it puts
you on a personal Crusade it's a
Crusades are not born of anything but
anger and uh and it's a righteous kind
of an anger not toxic no one's getting
hurt with this but I got mad that's a
good kind of mad and I'm not just gonna
sit here and stamp my feet I'm gonna do
something yeah I'm not going to take it
anymore right it's the old that was song
from the 80s Twisted Sister baby
I wish I had more hair yeah this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you've gone through Financial Peace
University chances are you did it
because someone in your life lit a fire
under your butt mom and dad gave it to
you as a gift your pastor offered it at
the church uh a friend that wouldn't
stop talking about it uh you finally
took the class you started working the
baby steps now everything's different
just like our last step free scream you
change your entire future now you can
light a fire under someone else there
you go this Christmas you can give
someone you care about Financial Peace
University
and share the same hope that you've
discovered with money
right now we're offering Financial Peace
University at the lowest price we ever
have
59.99
wow
that includes all nine lessons the
premium version of every dollar and
group Financial coaching this deal I
promise you will not last this is a
Christmas time special so you can give
this Christmas give the people you care
about a gift you act that actually
matters and that gift is called hope
it's called freedom to get Financial
Peace University for just 59.99 go to
ramsaysolutions.com give FPU see we're
kind of in the deflation I think you've
gotten the inflation I can get some memo
on our pricing since the season to make
things more expensive we've got
permission to do so dude yeah and I
didn't listen so our apparently our
marketing people didn't that's
ramsesolutions.com give
FPU that's the way you get it for 59 and
you can give it away Adam is with us in
San Antonio hey Adam welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking the call sure
what's up
well I currently live and uh work in San
Antonio and I just got a job offer in
Dallas now I bought the house it's
currently at about 320 got an equity of
160 in it and
a 3.75 interest rate now the job sounds
great but how much should I take as a
bonus or a raise to take this new job if
I know when I get a new house out there
it's going to be at seven almost eight
percent versus my 3.75
I'm currently making about 86 after
everything but before taxes and they're
offering you what
well we haven't gotten to the
negotiations yet I mean we're throwing
some numbers back and forth at each
other but I mean I just know that's
gonna
take a lot more out of my paycheck
paying that extra interest rate every
month
well I I don't think you what you get
paid somewhere is based on the interest
rate of your house yes
I think you know what you get paid
somewhere is what the market value at
the time of the job is
my question is I mean if you cut your
interest rate in half
and you've got a one point
whatever one and a half percent rate on
it
um
you wouldn't expect to get paid less
no I guess I'm just asking uh at what
point is it worth moving so um I I think
you I think you've got to back out of
this
here's what troubles me about this
mindset it says it's like you're
uncertain of the job you just accepted
or about to accept and you're making it
their responsibility to cover certain
things this is a math problem man come
up with I need this much money to make
this move and if you can't work we'll
shake hands and great if they can't if
if the market doesn't demand what
they're able to pay in that area but
you're making them well you make it now
what would make it fun do you think
um with the work I'd have to be doing uh
I don't know 94 95. okay what do you
think they're going to offer you
uh hopefully around there I mean uh this
is doing what
it's assessing buildings after uh
hurricanes and disasters
okay and you're an engineer did you say
uh we do forensic engineer work okay
assessing buildings hospitals after
disasters yeah I got you have you just
not
the main thing is I just know that's
going to take more out of my paycheck
every month sure but I've taken money on
that now I've taken several jobs in my
professional career at less money
because it was better for the season I
was in and it was going to provide an
opportunity for me to make like
significantly more money down the road
yeah 10 years from now do you want to be
in Dallas doing this or San Antonio
doing this with the two 10 years from
now you won't be working for the new
company or your current company
um probably a new one
probably what
the new one the new one okay all right
and so if you end up netting a little
less then I would and that's all the job
is worth
because I don't know what that's worth I
have no idea in Dallas Texas they might
offer you 140 for all I know you know in
which case it sounds like it's arbitrary
I shouldn't even worry about this at
this point I mean making enough I'm
comfortable I shouldn't let that math
scare me away from okay it's short term
you want to make the decision based on
long-term variables not the short-term
variable but I'm I'm concerned as to why
you are hesitant to put a number out on
the table and say this is what it's
going to take to get me
I would rather them put the first number
out because it might be more than I was
going to be that's true yeah
yeah I mean they're all going to giggle
and be like you got it dude
yeah why don't you see what they're
offering have you asked them Point Blank
what's the
no not yet the negotiation is just
beginning [ __ ] okay right yeah we've got
another one coming up yeah we talked
about I would do it the best thing you
can do in negotiating in general is
listen
and let them talk and then just say gosh
I'm you know one of the things I'm
struggling with has nothing to do with
what the job is worth I want to come
over there and add value and the job is
worth what the job is worth but I've got
a real good interest rate and I'm not
going to have one if I'm moving and
that's kind of coming into my math so
what are you all thinking and just you
know that's kind of you know but you're
you know I I would not say
uh if you're coming to me I'm an
employer I've got a thousand almost 1100
people here and you say I I want more
money because my interest rate is higher
I'm going to say no yes because that's
not a reason for me to pay you more the
reason I pay you more is you're worth
more
not because or the job pays more not
because you've got a higher interest
rate you know that you see what I'm
saying the the value of the position is
the value of the position
and um and it might be that in this
shortage of Labor economy that we have
with a great resignation the way things
are right now that they're going to
offer you uh north of a hundred I kind
of think that by the way yeah it
wouldn't surprise me so I'd be real
quiet and let them put a number out and
then just smile and here's here's a
little negotiating tip just for fun you
can just play with this if you want to
mess with it it's a great little
negotiating line no matter what they say
just smile and go wow that's impressive
thank you so much
um
is there any more you can do
and just ask and smile and say can you
do anything else because they probably
got a little bit of something you know
just to see what comes out I mean is
that the best you can do I'm laughing
right now because I asked you that exact
question and you said nope
well I've taught this on videos and I
assumed you had watched the video
exact conversation I know right where we
were nope this is it this is what we're
doing
and I lost like a sucker you didn't lose
you're here
I won big you didn't lose you're on
Jordan Peterson this week
I love it too fun yeah that's that's the
thing I always approach a job not by
what you need but by what the position
is worth
and that's a good a good thing and how
can I add value because all employers
have this formula folks all of us do and
the formula is I need to make more on
you than you cost me
otherwise I've got a whole bunch of
people in the building and I'm losing
money this is called layoffs are coming
right and when someone comes in and says
well I've got this degree and I'm worth
this much or I've got this much
experience I'm worth this much great but
that's your this position is not going
to make me that back I can't afford to
do that right I had a guy back in the
day there's only about 25 of us and he
came in and he said you know I've got
this degree in this degree and he had
more degrees than the thermometer yeah I
mean he was unbelievable and he's like
and if I was working at a Fortune 500
company here's what I'd be making
and I said well this is a small business
son
in small business year raised as
effective when you are cool
we don't want to give a crap what your
degrees are you can kill something drag
it home man we'll say we'll share it
with you but you stand around beating
your chest about where you went to
school all you're going to get is a sore
chest remember when I first started here
I asked one of the HR folks hey where do
I send uh my transcripts and they
started laughing he said
you can keep them
oh that's fun stuff this is the Ramsay
show
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Michelle is with us in Bend Oregon
starting off this hour hi Michelle how
are you
I'm great thanks how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
so I was just curious I was thinking
about my husband we're talking about
refi encing our vehicle and then taking
a personal loan so we can consolidate
our credit cards
um and I just want to know what your
thought would be on that it would be
like almost half the interest that it
was when I first got the the car two
years ago
um and then obviously the interest on
the personal loan is way less than the
credit cards so it makes sense to me
that I wanted your opinion what's the
balance
on the cars 12 000 500 and the credit
cards
about nineteen thousand okay all right
and what's your interest rate on your
car
uh currently I think it's at nine
percent about seven I think it's yeah I
want to say it's between seven and nine
I I'm not certain I and and the new rate
of your refinanced would be what uh I
have a quote from uh
Credit Karma for like 4.15
okay I doubt that's gonna happen in this
current environment zero percent chance
yeah
I think they're just trying to sneak you
in with oh we think you're about to get
paid I think you're about to get bait
and switched that's that's way below
Market rates okay but let's say you
saved four percent on
uh give or take on say ten thousand
dollars is 400 bucks
okay what's your household income
about 75 000 after taxes and the uh
interest rate on your credit cards
average on that about twenty thousand
dollar balance is what
I want to escape probably like 24
something like that probably closer to
20. yeah probably got some at 18. but um
yeah that's probably about right and
then the interest rate on the um
the offered refinance on that is how
much
9.63 or something like that all right so
uh 10 savings let's call it for round
number on twenty thousand dollars is two
thousand dollars
okay so you have you have thirty
thousand dollars in debt
and this move saves you two thousand
four hundred dollars a year
a year right you are not you do not have
a two thousand four hundred dollar
problem you have a thirty thousand
dollar problem right I understand that
yeah
but but what my thought was is that
though I've been with new program for a
couple months and um I've convinced my
husband he does the bills and I've
convinced him to stop putting little
extras here on every single one focus on
the smallest pay it off we paid off two
cards
um we've got the thousand dollars in the
savings yeah you're making progress I'm
trying yeah and I'm trying I want to
like hurry that you know
he doesn't see
the same way I
I 20 years ago here's the point here's
the point if you save 10 on this which
is approximately what you're saving
round numbers
um you you have addressed ten percent of
the problem
you still have 90 of the problem to
address
so if you want to do it that's fine
but it's laughable that you think you
did something
well
here I just said 90 of the problem is
still not addressed
got it you addressed ten percent of the
problem this is the problem with debt
consolidation
because debt consolidation
intellectually psychologically triggers
your brain and makes you think you did
something
it's like and you did you did do
something but it's only ten percent you
still have 90 of the problem and so we
have to address this on a higher plane
at a different level with a different
approach and if you want to do it that's
fine but I want you guys uh working
extra jobs not seeing inside of a
restaurant unless you work there I want
you saying no more vacations and we're
on a written budget and we're working
together and we're paying off these debt
smallest to largest and we sold so much
stuff the kids think they're next
okay and when you get there now you're
addressing the 90 if you also want to do
the other that's fine but when people do
what you're describing to me they don't
do the other and 88 of the time they end
up with more debt then that's what I
don't want yeah so that's kind of where
I'm at I like you know just keep
hammering away at the credit card so
what I would tell you is this you got 30
000 worth of debt if you can pay off ten
to fifteen thousand dollars by June 1st
without doing this then if you want to
refinance the balance of it at that
point because you've proven to yourself
you're willing to address the real
problem which is you got it you are the
real problem your husband is the real
problem then you can do this but I'm
afraid that you're going to activate the
part of your brain here's how you know
okay the the uh the Bible says the in
the abundance of the heart the mouth
speaks so the way what we think comes
out of our mouth if we're not real
careful okay including on the show
so here's what you said you said I'm
going to pay off my debt
you're no you're not you're gonna move
you're going to rearrange it you're
going to move borrowing it yeah you're
borrowing to lower interest which when
you know but my point is your heart is
feeling like you did something like I
paid it off right you didn't pay it off
you just moved it around a little bit
well and I know that and that's that's
part of the thing so one of the credit
cards that we owe on that we currently
owe on
basically he's not paying anything on it
so that was going to kind of cover that
too because
basically he pays 200 a month but it's
not taking anything off I pay minimum
payments on everything but your smallest
debt attack your smallest debt with a
Vengeance work extra sell stuff don't go
out to eat don't go on vacation work
extra sell stuff don't buy anything and
live on beans and rice rice and beans
where your friends think you've joined a
cult and your mother-in-law thinks you
need counseling and then what's going to
happen is you can pay off 30 000 making
75 000 in about 18 months doing that and
that's approximately two thousand
dollars a month
okay and you're a different person on
the back end
right I understand that it's just
getting him do you remember how old are
you how old are you Michelle
I'm 54. do you remember back in the
early 80s when a diet was Tab and like a
neutral light bar and a half of a
grapefruit
yes that's what you're trying to do
right you're trying to shortcut and hack
your way to this don't there's no hack
yeah I mean you're right getting him to
do the whole thing because here's what
happened interest rates did not put you
guys 30 000 in debt your decisions did
interest rates are not keeping you in
debt your decisions are and so again I'm
fine with you doing the refinance the
debt the debt consolidation it does make
mathematical sense but IT addresses 10
percent of the issue you've got to
address the other 90 or you're not going
to win and I've done you a disservice
unless I preach at you like this because
I love you and I want you to win thanks
for calling this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
deloney Ramsey personality is our
co-host today thank you for joining us
America number one best-selling author
of the book own your past change your
future he is featured on this week's
Jordan Peterson podcast if you want to
watch a long form on YouTube or listen
to it check it out I just came out today
I believe open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Randy's
with us Randy is in Cedar Rapids hi
Randy welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys I appreciate y'all taking my
call sure what's up
hey so I've been following y'all's
program for a while now and we've gotten
to the point where I'm in uh they just
does four five and six and
um just not really feeling traction and
so my question for you guys is uh is
there is there something I'm missing I
don't want to be just reactive to things
but proactive in some of this
um so we have what do you mean you're
not feeling traction
like it's been a couple years and like
life keeps hitting us so like for
example we had uh what's called a the
rate show which is basically an online
hurricane of sustained winds of 180
miles an hour so some stuff on an old
house that insurance won't cover that we
had to prepare
um we had two babies in the midst of
this journey as well so uh saved up for
those and paid cash for all those things
uh we now have paid for paid cash for
both of our reliable cars now that we've
upgraded so how old are you we've been
invest in uh 27 sir wow you're killing
it dude this is called life and you're
winning it yeah I mean I missed the part
where you're not getting traction what
are you talking about these paid for
storm repairs I mean you you know you're
rocking this
is we just we've been investing you know
15 20 now for for a couple years
uh not quite so that's what you should
not be doing by 15 percent
it uh we have two uh five years left on
our yeah you should be doing 15 at baby
step four onto your house no more not
20.
you gotcha so dial that back so you're
gonna have a paid off house when you're
32. you know who would trade places with
you everybody a couple 100 million
Americans
yeah let me let me let me let me in all
honesty let me tell you what I think it
is you thought
it would feel differently
and everyone I've ever sat down with
whether they are multi-multi
multi-millionaire or they're a pro
athlete or they thought that
there would be this resolution
that suddenly dad would text out of the
blue and be like hey I have never called
you intelligent I'm really proud of you
I want you to know I'm proud of you that
call is never coming right or that I was
just going to wake up and suddenly like
I'm a good looking guy I feel great that
that that that that resolution never
comes and so then you're in a like
you're in a position brother where
you're gonna start doing dumb stuff if
you continue to chase feelings instead
of just stay in the path stay in the
path stay in the path
because you're going to start seeking
feeling does that make sense
yes sir and people rarely cheat on their
spouse because of their spouse they
cheat on their spouse because it makes
them feel alive again
they rarely go buy a new sports car
because it's a great purchase but it
makes them feel alive for five seconds
and you're in danger of going down that
road if you if you deviate from the past
where the path is so important man
because it gives us something to lean on
when we quote unquote don't feel right
that's why I map out my workout programs
because I don't I don't feel like it in
the morning right but I've already got
it written out man stay on the path stay
on the path from two old guys way older
than you bro you are doing great so good
man stay on the path how often have you
heard that over the years oh it happens
all the time yeah when you get to baby
step four it just slows down that's it
changes it's the adrenaline changes from
intensity to life it's great to
intentional
and intentional is not nearly as
exciting as intensity yeah and so
intentional is a was a marathon
intensity is a Sprint it changes
everything
so good call good call Randy thank you
uh the uh
when I started on the show here 30 years
ago and for the first two decades after
that one of the big pariahs on the
college campus was they were getting
college kids in credit card debt credit
card people walking up and down the
campus handing out free t-shirts and
free pizzas and getting people in debt
most of the states and uh College
institutions have run the credit card
people off the campus they're somewhere
within a block away doing that stuff but
they're not physically on the campus
anymore uh but we've decided to replace
that with uh stupidity on steroids hey
this is way worse this is way worse this
is this activates a whole bunch of other
stuff that's cray-cray this is
unbelievable to me New York Times
reporting how colleges and sports
betting companies have caesarized campus
life in order to reap millions of
dollars in fees universities are
partnering with betting companies to
introduce their students and sports fans
to online gambling they sold their
students out
in September 2021 and officially
Michigan State University's athletic
department sent an email to his boss
with exciting news an online betting
company was willing to pay handsomely
for the right to promote gambling at the
University Alan if we're willing to take
an aggressive position we have a million
dollar a year deal on the table with
Caesars Paul shager wrote to Alan Haller
the University's athletic director in
the end the company proposed a deal
worth 8.4 million over five years other
schools too have struck deals to bring
betting to campus after Louisiana State
University signed a similar deal in 2021
with Caesars the university sent an
email encouraging recipients including
some students who were under 21 and
couldn't legally gamble to place your
first bet and earn your first bonus so
far at least eight universities have
become partners with online sports
betting companies or Sports books many
in the last year with more expected the
partnership raises questions however
about whether promoting gambling on
campus especially to people who are at
an age when they are vulnerable to
development Oak
and they're under your care you freaking
idiots unbelievable dude like Dave
I guess it's called it's hard for me to
catch my breath on this
this is the first time reading through
this this is insane to my colleagues at
universities across the country you
should be ashamed of yourself yes and
for those of you who've walked away from
this good for you for having some shred
of decency this is
God Almighty dude the number of gambling
addicts and all this causes So Much
Madness Downstream for a couple of
short-term bucks on the front end it's
disgusting selling out your own students
that you're supposed to you're selling
it for God Almighty dude unreally
unbelievable butts kicked up around your
neck and be wearing them like a collar
this is unbelievable
this is unfreaking believable LSU you
ought to be a shame to yourself
raise questions about whether promoting
gambling on campus especially to
children people who are vulnerable fits
the mission I'll answer it no there's no
question about it this guy says it feels
it just feels gross and tacky for a
university to be encouraging people to
engage in Behavior this addictive and
very harmful said Robert Mann an LSU
journalism Professor thank you for
standing up to your own University wow
unbelievable my University years ago I
took them to task University of
Tennessee on the air because they they
uh sold out to a credit card company
sold everybody's list all the alumni all
the students and Big Time check got a
big time check to sign everybody up for
the UT credit card yeah like I need a
smoky in my plastic all right well hey
piss me off I've I've struggled that
cost him a little bit of a donation or
two I've struggled for years years with
colleges who saddle up to alcohol
companies when the students when
alcohol is so destructive across a
college campus and I've been all over
the country having these conversations
with Campus Life leaders and college
presidents everybody this is I think
worse let me just tell you here's the
here's the numbers the number one
Addiction in North America today is not
drugs it's not alcohol
online porn that's right by far online
porn generates more Revenue than all
professional sporting put together
the number two
Addiction in North America today and
fastest growing Addiction in North
America today
gambling online gambling and it's
settled in it starts with the sports
betting is a gateway drug and um I mean
if you want to do it and you're 50 years
old and you've got ten thousand dollars
just to piss away that's fine you will
just call you stupid but when you're
serving up your students and you're
supposed to be they're supposed to be in
your care and they're going to be here
at University president or an athletic
department at a university you ought to
you ought to be fired or incompetent
immediately for endangering you greedy
sobs
unbelievable unconscionable
unbelievable yeah Caesar this oh my God
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Dr John deloney show
is my co-host today in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt-free stage
Ross and Abby are with us hey guys how
are you doing very awesome pleasure to
have you where do you guys live
West Plains Missouri now where is West
Plains 100 miles east of Branson 100
miles I go to West Plains twice a year
I've got sand I got some friends who
live there and they run a Boys Ranch
there in town Whetstone yes look at that
yeah West Plains very cool neat well
welcome how much data have you guys paid
off
70 200. all right and how long did that
take you
30 and a half months 30 months all right
and your range of income during that two
and a half years
it was sixty thousand to seventy eight
thousand excellent what do you guys do
for a living I'm a pastor and I work for
a local State Farm agent okay very good
and you are the numbers person Abby we
know this because he's been pointing to
you every time you ask a question he
knows how nervous I am oh okay
so you're not the numbers person no
you're not oh he deals with the spirit
she deals with the math no he's dealing
with him she said he's the numbers guy
okay good so what kind of debt was the
70 000. well about 10 percent of it was
uh be a combination of a health
Health Bill we'll say and um auto loan
20 to 30 percent of that would have been
a school loan and the rest of it was our
house oh you paid off
how much is this house worth
about 150 to 160. I love it and it's
yours how old are you guys
I'm 31 and he's 35. all right whoop
whoop not even 40 and you haven't paid
four house y'all are so weird I love it
way to go fun fun well tell us the story
what got you guys fired up on this two
and a half years ago well originally we
found out about your program uh through
my dad and we used to watch you on uh
Fox Business when you had your show on
there yeah back in the day and when we
got to married 11 years ago they sent us
through financial peace and instead of
the Dave plan was on the Ross and Abbey
plan for several years but
um
after we had our boy and then I was
going through Bible College and about
covet we decided you know let's take
care of this and start acting on how we
should so we started in on it uh well
January 1st I guess is before covet okay
and then just in time yeah we're going
to get out of debt just in time so what
happened to your incomes during covet
I was able to work from home
so I didn't miss any work
and I I preached online and they sent me
a check every week I never had a check
so yeah all right that's good very good
okay so we kept moving all the way
through it yeah and uh pushed on through
even in the middle of all that weirdness
and uh boy that it's it's strange God's
timing that he wakes you up in January
and then they shut the world down in
March right yeah
yeah it's one of them deals that just
worked out and we was both kind of ready
at the same time and she jumped on board
and if I set out a plan she'll pretty
well go with me whatever I want to so it
works out good okay so you drug out the
old financial piece and blew the blew
the dust off of it and went again huh
yeah
uh listen to several of your shows
currently get caught back up and
everything and read through a bunch of
books and what was the biggest
disagreement y'all had
sometimes I would cut our food budget
back to like next month we're not going
to spend any money on food just to see
if we could and she said can we just set
it and stop changing it you know I know
you're excited
that's probably the biggest one so yeah
we had the we had the argument over the
grocery budget one time to the point
that Sharon's so mad she's like well
then you go to the store stupid and buy
all of our food for 11. since you think
you can do it better have at it Bubba so
Ross that was a good answer that was a
good answer from you Abby what was your
biggest disagreement probably when he
would change the budget okay
I've gotten used to a certain number and
then
he'd go and change it I'd have to get
used to a new one yeah and and then you
said I'm not getting used to this one
you're going to change it back and then
he did yeah smart man good good good way
to go you guys how's it feel to not have
a payment in the world
feels pretty awesome
we actually had some our transmission
went out in our van last week of course
and um
kind of freaked out about it but we had
our emergency funds so we had the money
to do it but you know fight or flight at
that time but you didn't really want to
let it go
but we decided to go ahead and fix it we
don't like walk-ins yeah walking is it's
a bit bit of a hall there uh yeah very
good you guys very good very cool all
right what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um when I think about it yeah sorry go
ahead thank you she says don't give up
uh I think back to when you did your
2020 reset I believe it's an Oklahoma
City uh you said you'll get out of that
eventually if you'd start borrowing
money and you know that's pretty simple
and I'm kind of a simple guy that really
set home with me so I'd say stop
borrowing money
but uh that and of course budget as
everybody always says because it's
always true yeah yeah way to go you guys
very cool congratulations thank you
change of preaching
give me plenty of things to think about
and preach on yeah okay all right yeah
just the sense of Freedom uh sometimes
it does sometimes it doesn't sometimes
it just makes you uh more aware more
wise uh when you're looking over other
people's pain because you've been
through it seeing what people's going
through and understand yeah exactly
and sometimes it's compassion that you
get from it yeah very good I've got a A
friend of mine who says he doesn't trust
a man that doesn't walk with a limp
so I haven't been through that stuff and
you've worked your way through this it
makes you you know makes you aware very
good good job you guys great work great
work great work I'm proud of you very
good hey we've got the live and give
bundle for you uh that is The Total
Money Makeover book for you to give away
to someone I'm sure you'll be counseling
some young couple in church before you
know it since you're a young couple and
uh baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story we
want you to learn how to do that and go
ahead and plug that in the new version
of Financial Peace University the
membership to that is one year and yeah
let's bring the kiddos up and introduce
them give me their names and ages this
is Tate he's four and this is Hazel she
just turned one all right and she's a
Grandpa's girl I can tell she was
sitting with her Grandpa it's a good
girl all right good stuff you guys good
stuff you had good reasons to change
what was your why why was this so
important
stewardship we know we could do better
and wasn't and
we all need to yeah we can do better we
should imagine God's resources for his
glory yeah good stuff proud of y'all
well done well done Ross and Abby Tate
and Hazel West Plains Missouri seventy
thousand dollars paid off in 30 months
house and everything baby whoa they are
free I love it count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream ready
one one two three we're not free yeah
the places you can go the money you can
save the money you can give to help
others when you live in West Plains
Missouri with a paid four house and a
seventy thousand dollar household income
as a pastor the things he's going to be
able to do
unbelievable yeah it's a that's there's
Seasons when that's when that town like
many small towns Across America
struggles and man being able to be a
pastor that's free wow yeah put you in a
whole different mindset it's way
different than making 700 000 a year
living in
XYZ metropolitan area with debt up to
your dad gum eyeballs and can't breathe
it's a whole different life a whole
different quality of life whole
different quality relationships
everything and a pastor that has peace
radiating from inside it's it's they can
walk into people's hurt and walk into
people's pain and they just exhale right
instead of bringing their chaos with
them he's gonna be able to walk in a
situation she's gonna be able to walk
into situations people are struggling
and they're going to feel that on them
it's incredible yep powerful and changes
those little kids life change your
family tree man hey little Tate your
dad's a hero so is your mom
love it this is the Ramsay show
thank you
our scripture of the day Ecclesiastes 4
9-10 two people are better off than one
for they can help each other succeed if
one person falls the other can reach out
and help but someone who falls alone is
in real trouble
Dr Henry Cloud says there is a
difference between Solitude and
isolation one is connected and one isn't
Solitude replenishes isolation
diminishes oh that's good
sounds like Dr Cloud it sounds exactly
like Dr collage I love it good stuff hey
we're heading into the holiday season
where our brains are focused on buying
presents thawing turkeys and all the
Christmas New Year's celebrations all of
a sudden it's January
and then we're behind on everything hey
it doesn't have to be that way you can
start the new year strong set yourself
up to start the New Year Strong by
joining us for wealth for Building
Wealth live
here in Nashville January the 12th this
is a one-night event it's going to help
you kick off 2023 feeling confident
about your finances even in this crazy
economy Rachel Cruz George Campbell Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney and me join us
as we walk you through a simple proven
plan to be on track and actually build
wealth in the middle of all this uh
economy craziness our Building Wealth
events have been a huge hit we just
wrapped up the sold out fall season it
was incredible our January event will be
here in the Ramsey headquarters but
we're also going to Indianapolis Austin
Salt Lake City and Anaheim here in the
dates with dates in the spring all of
these are available at 39 seats seats
are limited be sure and check them out
go to ramsesolutions.com events
ramseysolutions.com events Neil is with
us Neil is in Chicago hi Neil welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey thanks for taking my call guys sure
what's up
hey um so I am in baby step 2 and um I
just lost my dad a little bit over a
week ago
when I'm just um when uh 11 days ago oh
my gosh Neil I'm sorry what happened
Neil
um we don't know one day we're talking
about
um bringing my fiance out to go visit
him in the next day he's on life support
oh man I'm so sorry oh man
um what was his name
his name was Carol Carol
how old was he
um 67. I'm sorry man
that was um a good man lost too soon
yeah absolutely
so that brings you you're on baby step
two you and your fiance were supposed to
go out to see him in 11 days ago you get
to deal with this for the last 11 days
uh yeah and um I you know I've been
working
um 40 to 80 hours a week for the past
two years I took out two student loans
my first two years of college but the
last two years of college I worked
full-time I had multiple jobs and uh I
was able to cash flow
um my my career
um my my degree
um so I've just been super good so
intense feeling a little you know burnt
out but I think this is just pushing me
over the edge
um just trying to
well I don't I don't know there's push
me over the edge as much as
yeah you had intentionally so you'd cut
your mind you got you got your knees
kicked out from it yeah
this was just a Wipeout man yeah
um you should be feeling overwhelmed and
you should be feeling heartbroken and
you should be unable to eat and unable
to sleep because your old man just
passed away
right all those fields are normal man
um yeah you need to push pause on
everything on your baby steps
okay do you have brothers and sisters
oh yeah okay about your mom
uh yeah she she she's still alive or
were they married
oh yeah
okay
have y'all had the funeral already
no um um I'm I'm going out to California
to see them in in a couple days okay if
you can stay a few days and have some
conversations with your siblings and
with your mom
and you may have to have some direct
conversations about what comes next and
whatnot but man punch pause on the baby
steps for right now okay this is a
season of grief it's going to be there
for a while okay
it would take normal people a little
while to get over this and I assume
you're normal
yeah I've just been you know trying to
stay positive and trying to work well
you're just trying to cope right now and
drive your car
yeah you know put some put some bologna
on the bread and eat I mean it's just
you're going through the motions you're
still breathe Just Breathe In and Out it
hurts
yeah I feel like if I just slow down on
it's just gonna hurt more no
no you're not you can't
um you can't pour water out of a glass
that's empty and yours just got emptied
your glass got shattered
so give yourself a little Grace breathe
if you're still talking like this in a
year and a half I'll probably have a
problem with that but you're not gonna
be that guy okay but you need to take 30
to 60 days for sure and just
breathe don't go buy something silly
don't be going into debt or something
like that but in terms of working in
tents and paying off debt and being
focused on all of that while you're
going through one of life's most
traumatic events no you take you take 30
to 60 off man here's something I want
you to do
um I want you to
go to the like a Walgreens or Walmart or
something like that and buy a couple of
sheets of nice paper
and I want you to write your dad a
letter
and tell them that you miss him
and in that letter
you can also be upset with him
be mad at him you shouldn't have left
I don't even know what happened
and then also tell them about this
fiancee of yours about what's coming
down the road
okay and that might be a letter that you
share with your siblings when you get
together in a couple of days for the
funeral there might be a letter you
share at the funeral might be a letter
to share with your mom but it's going to
be a way for your body to process this
in in conflict resolution there's always
a there's a saying conflict deferred as
conflict Amplified by not saying things
you need to say it just makes it worse
down the road the same thing applies to
grief if you try to avoid it work really
hard to try to avoid feeling how much
this hurts it's just going to turn into
a Cancer and so the best thing to do is
like Dave said take 30 60 90 days exhale
you got to keep working you got to keep
eating you got to keep sleeping
but fully lean into how bad this hurts
your dad died man
and nobody
um who has a good relationship with her
dad is upright in this position right
now okay you're right where you should
be
I'm so sorry to hear that man
thank you
I'm gonna send you a copy of John's book
on your past change your future I do not
want you to read it until after
Christmas okay
okay but after Christmas it'll help you
with the final stages of processing or
the next stages of processing some of
this and um
but how old are you
2023 just turned 23. yeah
so um how long you been in Chicago
uh for five years are you plugged into a
good church there by chance
um no not really not okay
you get you got some good friends in
your life
oh yeah I need to make sure they know
what's going on with you
yeah I have co-workers um
that are you know that that know about
it they're picking up some slack yeah
but not just text messages you'll need
to go you say hey I needed some I need
to get some pizza tonight who's in
yeah and y'all go sit and look at other
people in the face and you're gonna find
because you've been working really hard
the last few days when you sit down and
you actually exhale and you start
looking at other people and they look
back at you you're gonna get hit waves
with heavy emotion and don't run from
that okay it's part of being sad it's
part of the grieving process everybody
does it different
okay I appreciate it don't hide from
this and don't hide from other people
okay
uh humans need humans especially in
times like this brother you call here
anytime we can help you okay so check
back in let us know how you're doing let
us know how your mom's doing if we can
help her with any in this process we
will
um it's one of the mandates on us and so
you just let us know anything anything
we need to do man hang on uh we'll have
Austin pick up and get you a copy of
that book
and Dave that's a good reminder as
people head into the holidays there's
going to be a swath of people who sit
down for Thanksgiving and there's
somebody missing at that table
somebody's at Christmas there's going to
be a few fewer presents under that tree
and it's okay if this isn't just the
joyous season for you right if it's a
season of grief and a season of sadness
season of remembrance that's part of
part of The Human Experience
doesn't have to be all plastic and
facade that's right that puts this hour
the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 mil
will listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign